Station five with faith and. Side B. and The tape will begin in about ten seconds time and of identification.
Do you want to just continue where you left off talking about. Paul and Poppy WILLIAMS Singing lessons of course.
Yes So poor introduced me to shoot it. And he introduced me also to work war and to work peace was all about.
And in that tiny flat there.
It was also a center for people who were for peace and at that stage who we were working against the continued.
Manufacturing of the atom bomb. Because Hiroshima and Nagasaki. We're still very fresh. You know.
And we had a petition going to have the atom bomb. And there in that time a little you know we would meet.
With and just discuss ideas about peace and about war
and if ever there was one who was an authority to speak on the horrors of four it was poor.
And then I would say Paul was in his mid sixty's or so.
And he'd experienced the first world for he was in Russia just before the recent revolution. In.
And he was able to compare. The situation in what became the Soviet Union. With.
The situation under serfdom and the situation under communism.
And he said whether or not people hated the fact that it became a communist state
and the thing is that he lifted the surface.
And this little flame became more than just a place for me to learn about music.
It became a place for me to understand what politics were about.
We had very beautiful music leading in that little room to raise funds for the New South Wales Peace Committee.
The New South Wales Peace Council I think it was named. And I think that was. Around about forty or so.
Considered this government as a dangerous rigid organization.
That was they had to be virtually wiped out but they had people in it who were made of steel
and we weren't going to be wiped out. People like Bob am poor off. I often felt I was not with any of these two people.
Culturally they were just rich. Materially of course almost poor. And. But we always very special.
But you had just she also had a terrible slave as you see she was still very young so I was about twenty eight twenty
six or something. Terribly young. And there was very little in because not that many people.
From Paul but we had quite a few doing piano. But there wasn't a lot of money to throw or.
And one afternoon when I arrived from Alice and she just came in also.
She had a parcel and what have you got there and she says. But a new dress.
And she had paid seventy twenty seven pounds pounds for dray she'd seen in a window at the cross.
Grain which had re-used patterns of white flour was lovely daisies on it you know.
So she opened it up and just looked at it. Currently seven pounds.
I made your price even pounds those days for interest and think you are doing pretty well. To pay twenty seven pounds.
But when she played the daisies were on the side of the audience.
And she looked heavenly beautiful and she had this beautiful. That she would talk to back in a ponytail.
And she like her friend the musician.
Would usually ruin it all for me because I would find I would be just concentrating on the piano not on my voice.
They certainly were. And then fifty fifty. I actually had to give up. That's true in Downing Street.
And I can't remember why. But I've been looking around for a. Her Place. Really.
And I was at Lilly Williams flat right. Drinking coffee. And talking politics with a few blokes.
And among them was the poet new home. Who was a very senior public servant.
But he was also very quietly working for the New South Wales Pisco school
and Lily was working full time for that council and he was there when I arrived
and they were talking of making plans for what the council should be doing.
And literally just sort of offhandedly said. Well Dowling have you found another place maybe another place to live.
And I said no hasn't really been I'll get mad if I stay in Africa maybe longer. So about two days three days later.
How much hope and powers are the power. I can't remember she sent me a note I think.
And she said We bought a house and perhaps you might like to live in the flat. We've been living in.
Well it happened that they were living. In the flat of. Adamson battlers and Mary Adams.
In McLean Clarence Street in Old Sydney but was a very famous writer
and powered he worked for the Bulletin during the Depression years a very good journalist
and they were going to live for several months in Czechoslovakia or twelve months or something like that with ace.
Who was involved in making films. Rod.
And he said look you can go into the flight because we're going into our house would cure a belief.
And so I went and lived in a flat in Sydney it was the Adamson's flat.
I started this friendship with that was in fifty. And I had lunch with her yesterday.
And it's coming a fifty years since I've known her.
But that kind of took me out of you know why it took me out of that beautiful atmosphere at Kings Cross.
I was I didn't go back. Of course because I went out of Paul but I continued my music lessons with Paul.
Now it was suggested to me to cultural festival in Berlin. And that was suggested to me early one nine hundred fifty.
I was a bit history to pass that they were awful lot of communist involved in the organization.
And I didn't want to be pushed around. No believe me you know.
But I just then I met Margaret for the dancing teacher and she said well I've created this dance.
It has to do with racial discrimination and perhaps you take the part of the ever shorter.
But you have to come to Berlin with us. And she said Oh well you've got to go out to look around to it and.
It will cost four hundred pounds out of money and. Yes on the boat. So I said Oh well I'll give it some thought and.
Then people began to say to me you've got to fight. You've got to. You have been a wonderful experience.
And I began to see myself gathering not a crack I did not mention.
I have to keep the straight because there are also lots of things popping into Vanguard at the moment.
Terrific things happening by then I had a. I was in almost a permanent relationship name of. Poet.
He was a boilermaker. And I want to talk about. I think you should talk about him because he changed my life.
I cannot talk about him. There was a woman born of African father.
I'm not sure but maybe an Aboriginal mother but I'm not sure about that.
And when her mother two sisters when her mother died. The father took them to St Joseph's home. For all of that out.
And she was brought up to a bad man. And then played.
House sight reading was perfect just perfect that it was a very sad
and terrible time in many ways that was the time
when children were beaten with the handle of the dust feather duster if they didn't play the right notes.
And that's what she went through they are.
Finally when she was about sixteen or so and could play complement brilliantly. The father wouldn't got her.
And got her a job at the tearfully theatre. He was in theatre great actor. Told me. And.
She married a man who bought a house in Raleigh street behind the wood Women's Hospital.
And she kept that house beautifully. Anyhow she threw him out after a bit. They were divorced and she had one daughter.
But she and her living by playing the piano. She still alive. She related to call now. She wasn't related. But.
Sunday night at her house was a great gathering place and some of her. I went to regulate. With music this.
And she play for me.
And all the great neighbors would all come and stand in the street
and she'd leave the front door open so they could hear it was a like a concert. When I was. It's Matel go.
And it was a typical terrace house you know nobody waved unless they took a contribution to supper not that you
expected it. But I want to get togethers and so my sister Renie a very beautiful voice would get around the piano.
And one evening we were there and there was this man. And the next Sunday.
There was this man and I I noticed that he knew very well and she knew.
And so he said to me would you like to see film. And I said yes and. So he took me to see a film called.
I think it was on the life of show page. I forgot my Pipelet doesn't matter. I thought it was just it just lovely.
Well I can say that was the beginning of a seven year very close relationship.
So when I was about to talk about going to believe me I was away for eleven months
and for eleven months every fortnight while in London I picked up a money order from him
and he said you've got to see Europe.
And you can go to concerts and you enjoy yourself and it was marvelous just wonderful.
I'm not going to talk any moment this morning that it can I leave that now. Because things are getting a bit confused.